- [Host] Pop quiz
hotshot, you're in Harlem
and you're at this building.
You go through the door,
enter the security code,
take the elevator to the third floor,
knock on this door where Rudy greets you.
- Hi and welcome.
- You make your way
into a packed apartment
and try to find a seat.
What do you get?
(jazz music)
You get a live jazz
performance like no other.
(applauding)
Every Sunday, Marjorie Eliot
and her son Rudel Drears
open the doors to their
apartment for people
to come and listen to jazz music.
- We decided to use our apartment because
we can do what we want here. (laughing)
It's just a matter of this is home.
So everybody who walks through that door,
we treat as family.
- [Host] And it's a pretty big family.
The concerts are so popular
that if you're not on time,
finding a seat can be a little tricky.
- We fill up the living room,
the kitchen, the hallway,
and people just stand out taking videos.
It's pretty much like
that every Sunday now.
It's jam packed.
(mournful jazz music)
- [Host] The jazz concerts began in 1993
after Rudel's brother Phil passed away.
- Well, my brother passed away on a Sunday
and mama had the great idea to honor him
with concerts on Sundays.
You know, when you play music, you
just get all your angst out
and it's just a healing feeling.
So, I think her thing was, you know,
what better way to honor him
than with a concert?
And we've been blessed to
never have missed a Sunday.
(applauding)
(upbeat jazz music)
- [Host] With their
commitment and consistency
to play every Sunday, the concerts are now
considered legendary in
Harlem, attracting audiences
from all over the world.
Hey Rudel, do you mind if we ask some of
the audience members where they came from?
- Of course.
- I'm from Germany.
- France.
- Australia.
- Colombia.
- That's pretty cool.
♪ Oh when the saints, oh when the saints ♪
♪ Go marching in, go marching in ♪
- [Rudel] I think once we
started it just took on
a life force of its own.
Sometimes people come and they just,
they don't know what they're gonna expect.
You know, it's like, ring
a bell and get free jazz?
And then once they get here,
they have that experience,
it's kind of something they won't forget.
For some people this is their church.
People come here and they feel renewed.
And we feel renewed.
And you never know who
you're gonna touch out there.
So, if you're putting out
good energy, it's gonna work.
(audience exclaiming and applauding)